Make sure you guys hit the subscribe button.
If you guys are enjoying the content that we're throwing up and make sure you
guys hit the like button, if you enjoyed the video and yeah, let's begin.
All right, what's going on.
Guys. This is Rob and we are continuing our Dawn of X coverage. Yes we are.
And in this video we are picking up with Excalibur.
Here's the cool thing about this, but here's the cool thing about this.
This is really going to kind of allow us a chance to offer some pretty cool
explanations. And so far as how are the captain Britain core works?
Jonathan Hickman's Avengers, a new Avengers, the collapse of the multi-verse,
how all that stuff ties into what's going on right now with this X-Men run.
This is why I always tell people,
if you want to read Jonathan Hickman's work, read it by itself.
Do not read anything else unless you absolutely have to.
This is an example of where you kind of have to write because other people are
writing the swords of X story, as opposed to just Jonathan Hickman.
And it all basically ties together,
but you can literally just read Hickman by himself and read nothing else.
And just maybe catch up on a couple of things here and there.
But the cool thing here is it offered, it allows us a bit of an explanation,
but before we get to that point,
we pick up with the arrival of Jamie Bradick and Brian Bradick as they've been
summoned by Saturday. And the whole idea is that as they're meeting, uh, Betsy,
Bradick here, right as they're meeting, you know, captain Brittany here,
once they arrive, things get pretty murky pretty fast.
And the reason why is because as Brian Braddock shows up here,
that's you realizes he's in possession of the sword of mite. And when she asks,
why is that here? His response is because I brought it for you. And the,
the idea of Brian Bradick is to basically switch these things right,
for Brian to retake the ambulance and for, for Betty, uh,
for Betsy to take the sword of Mike. Now,
here's the reason why that matters because once all that passes and they're
basically met by the arrival of Saturday and that she's assembled them here,
and it looks like it's basically a kind of giant get together to honor the
fallen captain Britain core that existed before the events of Hickman's of
vendors and new Avengers. But the idea is that this,
this kind of argument is taking place in such a way to where Brian wants things
to go back to the way they were before that one of the things that Saturday
talks about is the fall of the captain Britain court. Now,
the way this worked was the result of Hickman's offenders into new Avengers,
right?
So the captain Britain Corps in previous years was largely created by Merlin and
then Roma, and a combination of both. And the way this will play out,
is that an,
any one universe on any one earth out there that what you would have,
if some individual who would be met at some point in time by Merlin or Roma or
both, and what they would do is they would present them with an option.
They would say,
you have the choice of the sort of mite or the amulet of right there.
Wasn't really a wrong answer there, but whichever one they took,
they would go forward with those corresponding powers and they would in effect,
become the captain Britain of their universe.
And the idea is that the captain Britain of that universe,
which serve to protect that universe, but also serve as part of a larger whole,
they would protect the multi-verse alongside other captain Britain members.
And so think of it as a more localized version of like, I'm sorry,
a much larger version of the green lantern Corps.
And so the result of this is that during Jonathan Hickman's Avengers and new
Avengers, as we covered with that story,
that there came a point where Saturnino and the Omni Versal development court
were trying to understand why the multi-verse was collapsing,
why they didn't fully understand it.
And so what they ended up doing was getting their hands on a map maker with a
desire to crack the map maker, understand its code, and then get a,
get a bigger picture. Sure.
The problem with this was that the map maker ended up submitting its own forces,
right? And it really was more of a Sierra Madre,
so that as opposed to a map maker,
but they ended up somebody in the forces of both the ivory Kings and the ivory
King soldiers,
and this led to the complete and total annihilation of the captain Britain
court,
the only person who survived was Brian Braddock and Ryan Radek only survived
because Saturday took all the knowledge of the Starlight Citadel, right?
So all information containing the existence of the multi-verse and everything
that she knew about the multi-verse and literally use telepathy to put it in the
mind of Brian Bradick and then cast him out, right?
And he basically ended up showing back up to the Illuminati at some point in
time, but that's how they captain Britain core fell.
Now following the restoration of the multi-verse,
the category and core was not restored.
The reason for that is because the method and manner of choosing the captain
Britain court is not arbitrary, the sort of mite or the amulet of right.
And in years past, this is kind of what's happening says here in years,
past captain Britain's,
who were chosen for that particular had to undergo that test.
What we're told here is there are captain Britains out there in the multi-verse,
but Saturday and considers them to be heretical. She's considered them to be,
to be heretics because they have not undergone the process of choosing between
the sword or the ambulance as well,
because they have not undergone that traditional process.
They're not real captain Britain's for all intents and purposes,
the way the Saturday views it. Somebody just grabbed a captain Britain uniform,
slapped it on, and now they're that character,
but they're not the rightful character. They have an undergone the process.
A person should undergo an order to become that in order to overtake that role.
And so, because of that, while there are captain Britain's there,
she's basically captured them and she's holding them until she decides when
they're ready to be destroyed. And so in this frustration and this irritation,
as far as Saturnino is concerned while Brian Braddock is not in possession of
the ambulance, he isn't possession of the, of the sort.
And Brian Brodick is the only true captain Britain,
but Betsy Bradick is not the Bessie.
Braddock is considered to be a heretic and the eyes of Saturday.
And this really is kind of doubled down by Betsy's own admission.
What Saturday makes the case about the sword and the amulet. And Betsy says,
I never had to make either choice. And that's when Saturday is like,
those are your words, not mine in effect in the eyes of Saturnian Betsy,
Brodick doomed herself.
And she basically gave Saturnian license to take her captive. Right.
And that's what she kind of says, like the exits that way, right?
You don't need to be here. Like there's no reason for you to be here. Now,
Ashley goes to kind of make her way she's met by Bryant.
And the crazy thing about this is that she kind of challenges Brian to a fight,
right? She's like, let's get the song, right? Let's let's,
let's figure this out once. And for all, like who is the actual captain Britain?
The cool thing about this.
And what's interesting here is that Brian's response is I gave you the amulet.
If you guys remember the Excalibur story, the first one that we did,
his response was I gave you the ambulance because I was being taken over by
Morgan Le Fay. In this moment,
when I was basically being transformed into her henchmen,
I did not want her to have a henchman that had the power or of the ambulance.
So I gave it to you, but this was only ever meant to be temporary.
That ultimately I knew that you guys would win against Morgan Le Fay.
And when that time came, I hoped that you would give the amulet back to me.
That's why I gave you the sword.
The response of Betsy is I don't want to give it back to you.
I like being captain Britain. I want to stay captain Britain. The whole idea of,
of, of Brian Bradick is, but you don't even live in England.
Like you live in Coca-Cola, you live in a whole different place.
What kind of captain Britain could you possibly be?
If you don't even live in the place you represent, right.
It doesn't really make any sense.
It's like a president of the United States that lives in Japan.
It's nonsensical. There's no, it just,
it just doesn't work that way right now at this point,
it's really just kind of arguing geographic location.
But if we're being honest with ourselves,
because a captain Britain can become that way by taking the sword or the amulet,
then we're really just kind of arguing.
Semantics is really what's happening here. That's all is coming down to.
But the funny thing about this is that as they kind of begin to get into the,
to a little bit of their fights,
Betsy Braddock does make a really good point in saying that becoming captain
Britain is an honor. It's not a birthright, right? You're not owed this.
You're not owed the role of captain Britain, despite what the lineage is.
And despite your ties to King Arthur, you're not owed this role.
You have this role bestowed upon you at one point in time,
but it could also have been taken away.
And if it can be taken away from you that it's not a thing that you inherently
own, right?
It's the thing that's just given to you for some temporary amount of time.
Even at that temporary amount of time just happens to be your entire life.
It can be taken away at any point in time.
And so what you end up doing here is you kind of have this,
this whole situation that's kind of interrupted right by Saturday, you know,
and she's like, you guys need to calm down.
But the funny thing about this is she kind of seems to be sewing discord among
the two, right? Like she kind of seems to be creating a rift among these two.
Now what we end up doing is picking up later that night. And when that happens,
you end up having, uh, having, you know, Jamie,
Jamie who's kind of sleeping in his guest quarters and is met by what are,
what's essentially an assemblage of captain Britons that are different other
different characters based on the X-Men right?
So rogue who's a captain Britain gambit, who's a captain Britain Jubilee.
That kind of a thing as a result of this is that they basically say like,
we sentence you to die right now, the motivation for why they send some to die.
We're not really given a definitive explanation here instead,
what is happening and, and,
and how it looks as though Jamie may have sold them out. But the,
but what it looks like happened here,
or at least what does happen here is you have Betsy and you have Brian who of
course respond. And then once they get in there,
Jamie's got all these guys seized right now. Again,
Jimmy Bradick can warp reality on a universal scale.
And that's what those strings are, right? Those strings that emanate that's him.
That's how it is that he controls reality.
Now this is just kind of shown to us for artistic license.
It's just kind of shown to us like,
this is what he's actually doing in terms of how it is at like Betsy and Bryan,
Bryan. Bradick see it.
He's just standing there and they're floating in thin air and all hell's popping
loose. Right? That's, that's all it kind of looks to them.
This is just kind of shows that we can get an artistic understanding of how his
powers work. But the whole point behind this is he's kind of like, okay,
they showed up here with the intention of killing me.
I can't just let that slide, but if I can't kill them all,
then I'll just kill one to help them understand their place, your picture.
And so in doing that, he kills the captain Britain Jubilee, right?
He kills the Jubilee version of captain Britain. And so once she's dead,
it off all the others, right. They go after them and they end up taking off,
right. They ended up basically bailing out.
Radek ultimately ends up drawing the sword of Mike from the scabbard.
And when he does,
he becomes a version of captain Britain using the sword of Mike right now at
that moment, he in turn,
turns it on the rest of the captain Britain core and says, okay,
they will strike you down if I have to, I don't want to,
but I will kill you if I have to. But that's when Saturn needs steps in.
And so she basically, she, she kind of appeals to Brian.
Bradick right with this idea kind of, kind of appealing to him.
It's his manly nature, right? Being a little romantic and so on. And the same,
like, you know, get rid of this sort of my, you don't need this anymore. Right?
I am the sole occupant of the Starlight, Citadel Merlin and Roma or long debt.
I determine who's going to be the captain Britain from this point going forward.
And so she basically tells them, get rid of the sword.
She tries to strip the amulet away from Betsy Bradick with the intention of
giving it to Brian. But Betsy uses it combination of her, of her power,
along with some spells,
learn from apocalypse and destroys the amulet and the process. Now,
the reason why this matters is because the amulet is what gives KA though that
version of captain Britain, their power, right?
So like flight forcefield different than that, that suit, you know,
enhanced strength, super speed. So on and so forth. Without the amulet,
those powers can't freely be given, right.
It would have to be restored or something along those lines.
As a result of that,
she ends up having Betsy body taken away and takes Brian to what is basically
her bed chamber. And so, as a result of this, you pick up with,
with Betsy Brodick right. Kind of down in this holding cell.
And she kind of tries to reach out so far. She hasn't really been successful,
but she tries to reach out and is ultimately met by the gambit version of
captain Britain from, from whatever alternate reality that happens to be.
And once you basically says is at least having this conversation with them,
she asks like, you know, are you guys okay? What is everything? Okay. And the,
the, the funny thing is like, she tells him like, we'll try it. Like,
I'm going to try to find a way out.
But what she's told by gambit is escaping the cells is no small thing.
If all you had to do is pick a lock and leave.
It wouldn't really be much of a prison cell.
And so what he tells her is there are spells bits around this cell and the way
in which it works is that when Roe tried to break out,
she literally just drives her,
fly out of it and got exceedingly cold and she can't get any warm net. Right?
Like she got cold, she got lost and she can't warm up. Right.
So there's an effect that it has on you.
It's that kind of magic that keeps people contained within these cells.
And so what is happening is that while she's telepathically communicating with
gambit, the Jimmy Bradick piggybacks onto their communications. Right. And says,
okay, so like, you need to jump out, jump out the window now,
and I will catch you. What I mean, they're,
they're so high up that if you were to jump out and you'd probably end up
getting yourself killed when you hit the ground.
And the fact that she doesn't really have the,
it means per normal powers of the powers of cat of Britain, aren't readily,
readily available to you. Now,
you could kind of ask the question if she really is that powerful in terms of
her telekinesis, why couldn't she just fly? That's a good question to ask.
I don't know why we don't get an answer to that,
but it kind of seems to be this sort of revolving spell that exists right there.
Like if she jumps out the window and then she gets caught up in the spell.
And so the response to this of, of, of Jimmy Bradick is okay,
you could stay here, but keep in mind,
you're in other world and they're going to execute you at Dawn. So when you die,
like if you die or when the time comes, if you're executed and you die,
they can bring you back on cacoa. But remember guys,
if you die in other world and they resurrect you in Precoa you come back,
all screwed up, right? You come back all twisted and screwed up.
We saw that in the last couple of videos that we made.
That's one of the important points about dying in other worlds that remains for
the rest of swords of X. If you die out there,
there's no guarantee to the version of you that comes back will be the version
who died. It could be any other alternate reality version of yourself, right?
So maybe Betsy Brodick jumps out or she's executed in the morning and Kurkova
resurrects her. And she comes back and it's like some crazy, some,
some absolutely nuts girl who's helped been on world domination, right?
There's no way of knowing if that's going to be the case, right?
No way of knowing what version of her will come back. And so, because of that,
you end up having her, of course, making this leap of faith out the window,
and then being caught by a Griffin, right? Th that belongs to, uh,
to Jimmy Brodick who of course rescues her.
And the two of them make their way towards Saturday Dean's bed chamber.
And as she's there, what she ends up doing is basically telling Brian Bradick,
you're the one that needs to represent this prophecy, right?
You're the one that needs to wrote to, to basically wheel this Starlight.
Sor not Betsy Bradick, she's not a real captain Britain. This has to be you,
you have to be the one to return to wheel this weapon.
And so what she ends up doing is basically crafting the Starlight sort itself.
Now, one of the things to keep in mind here,
and this is something that we may not have really covered,
or hadn't been too clear on is that this whole idea that, of course, you know,
once Betsy Brodick and them show up, you know, and like,
literally you have Saturday making out with Brian Braddock, right? So, you know,
like let's, let's touch naughty bets, right? You have like a,
you have bet Syria, and you have, uh,
Jamie who were kind of watching everything go down.
And then Brian Bradick realizes she's there. And he's like, Betsy,
take the sword now. Right. Betsy runs in grabs a sword.
And we realized that Brian Bradick was never actually on the side of Saturday.
And, but he was basically playing her in order to give Betsy time to steal the
Starlight sword herself.
Because that's part of the prophecy for the swords of X event.
One of the things to understand here is this prophecy is not something that
predates satiny, right?
It's not as though it's a prophecy that's been around for like millennia.
And it's just now coming to fruition.
This is a game that Saturday Dean herself created, right.
She created the prophecy, she created all of this, right.
It's kind of her great, big, huge game to just sort of see what happens.
We don't really know what the end result of this is.
We don't really know what it is that she's trying to achieve.
What's the point of standing in the way of the forces of, of,
of a Rocco that wants to invade the main Marvel universe and kill everybody
there. What's the point of that, right? If you're in the Starlight Citadel,
what's the whole point. I mean, you're not really affected by any of it.
So why does it matter to you? Right.
We don't really know what the end result of her whole campaign is.
What we do now is this kind of effort between Brian and Betty has ultimately
worked that what it's done is this drove sadder Nene to create the Starlights
award,
which was the missing weapon that they needed in order to secure the forces of
earth budding as the forces of a Rocco. And so now they have both,
they have the sort of mind and they have the Starlight sword.
And so it solidifies this position. Right? And so from here,
it just boils down to three more sorts. Right? All we have are three more.
My question here,
and this is the question that I feel like a lot of you guys are asking my
question here is when are we going to see the return of mad Jim? Jasper's,
that's what I want. I want to see Jim Jasper's come back. I want to see him.
And I want to see the fury. I want to see that. Cause the theory we should,
I don't know if we ever did no mega mega level video on the fury.
I think we did. And if we did, uh, you know, the, my,
my guys will have it down in the description.
The fury is wildly overpowered while he's insanely powerful. It's,
it's kind of nuts. But with that being said, guys,
we're going to read this video to an end.
If you are new here to come and explain to make sure you guys have the sub
button to become part of the rod port. If you guys enjoyed this video,
make sure you drop a light. Now we'll catch you up.
Bruce.
[inaudible].